[Music]
foreign
thanks for convening a short notice I
can't believe it
oh here we are this is atomic test
the Russians have a bomb we're supposed
to be years ahead of them but
what were you guys doing in Los Alamos
and how many people were in these uh
open discussions too many
compartmentalization was supposed to be
the protocol we were in a race against
the Nazis
so now the race is against the Soviets
not unless we started Robert they just
fired a starting gun
[Music]
it's a nature of the class they
designated data indicates it may have
been a plutonium implosion device like
the one you built at most
foreign
[Music]
why would I leave my family I told you
you can bring your family I'm not a
soldier hobby Soldier he's a general
I've got all the soldier I need what can
I tell them as much as you like them
until you feel my boot on your balls you
know Isotopes and you know explosives
you can't tell us what you're doing
why would we go to the middle of nowhere
for who knows how long are you or two or
three
Stop Force
before the Nazi style oh my God how
about because this is the most important
thing to ever happen in the history of
the world
here you go to little town
everybody will go crazy
they both let me leave I won't let you
leave
[Music]
it's happening isn't it
foreign
[Music]
thank you
you felt your judgment was sounded home
the team could be trusted no one is
leaving Los Alamos what are you doing
[Music]
we had a moment where it looked like the
chain reaction from an atomic device
might never stop it are we saying
there's a
chance that when we push that button we
destroy the world chances are near zero
near zero what do you want for Theory
alone
zero would be nice
[Music]
for the Japanese surrender if they knew
what was coming
[Music]
foreign